how do you share that you care is care
measured in the size of the bonus or the
free coffee caring as a language comes
in all forms for some people it's money
for some people it's better coffee for
some people it's a pat on the back for
some people it's a promotion for some
people it's having compassion when they
need some time off there is no one care
language and that's why so many
operators and leaders and business
owners struggle they only have one move
they think that if they're giving
everyone a raise everyone should be
[__] estatic well guess what [__]
[__] a lot of people don't care just
about the money you can give them a
triple raise but if you make them feel
like [__] 34s of the time they're not
going to like their job for a great
business we try to win on everything the
emotions the imperative side things the
salaries the titles you have to realize
that everybody has a different care
language and you need to try to fulfill
that if you're trying to build something
substantial